[Music]
okay everybody I am so so excited today
because I am joined by Lauren lovera AKA
Sienna in terrifier two we're going to
be talking spoilers about the film so
make sure you watch the film first and
come to this interview Lauren how are
you doing today
I'm doing great I'm so excited to talk
to you about this film that's just like
sleeper hit everybody's talking about so
I'm honored to be talking to the star of
it now put me in your shoes though for a
second when you got the part of this
role did you watch terrifier one before
you got the part or after and were you
kind of like what am I getting myself
into here uh no I did not watch it
before I got the parts I probably but I
was aware of it I knew it existed and I
saw the poster on Netflix and I remember
seeing like Dave in the art the clown
get up but in on the poster being like
Oh my God that looks awesome and I've
had people before I knew about it was
like oh you gotta watch terrifier it's
really cool because they know I love her
and I just never got around to doing it
um but then I had my first self tape
where I did it home with my
um with my coach and I didn't have the
time to watch it then and by my callback
came around I didn't get the time to
watch it then and then I had my
in-person audition and I had the time to
watch it but then I had been kept I kept
receiving the callbacks so I was like
all right well I guess they like what
I'm doing and I don't want to watch the
film because maybe it'll like persuade
my choices so I decided not to watch the
film and I watched it the same day I
found out I was cast and wow
that's that's great story yeah that
makes sense to wait for it too I like
that and what's interesting too and I
noticed you're rocking it right now is
that septum piercing I love that thing
but what I want to bring that up is
because I like that the character of
Sienna wears it and we see it which you
don't see much in TV you see a lot of
actors with it but not in the character
so how did that was that like a hard
Choice like did you have to convince
someone to do that because I like it and
I feel like it was something Brave in a
sense I love that question you're the
first person to ever ask me that
question I actually never do myself
tapes or my auditions showing my septum
piercing I usually [ __ ] it up
um because like you I've done it a
couple times I went in a casting office
a couple times and got a little berated
by the casting director they were like
don't wear that tuck that up and I was
just like all right fine
um but then I think Damien saw me with
it and he was the one that was like keep
that I like that okay but when I was
like so I didn't have to convince
anybody they just liked it Damien liked
it so I was like cool like it I get to
bring a part of myself off to Sienna
which I'm always trying to do with my
characters find a part of myself and
inject it in the character so it was
very cool to be able to keep oh hell
yeah I like that and yeah it totally
just worked as a character choice I
thought it was great and I also you just
mentioned that you like to have part of
yourself in the character I'm wondering
then
how much of yourself did you find in
Sienna what kind of spoke to you a lot
well the fun thing is my very first
audition my very first scene was between
Sienna and Barb so Sienna and her mom
and she was I mean at this time being
raised by a single mother and I was
raised by a single mother and my first
audition was a bit of like a
argumentative scene which me and my mom
have had plenty of those so it was very
easy to like align with Sienna like
almost I've been in this situation
before I know what this is like so
definitely relationships the
relationships she has with her friends
and the relationship she has with her
mom are the closest to home for me I
mean I have the best friends in the
world no one would ever drug me like
Brooke does
um but we're we love each other in the
same way that Sienna loves her friends
oh I like that answer and yeah I like
you mentioned relationships because I
think that's another underrate thing
about this film is how good the
relationships are and it's a props to
you and your co-stars for sure I also
love uh this clown Cafe nightmare
sequence so so is this song still in
your head today as it is mine when I
watched the movie
did you go down so smoothly a slide
backwards
oh I was so I was so excited to go down
that slide
um I don't know if that was a direction
or if I was like can I go down the slide
it was very like we were all kind of
doing things on the Fly which I really
appreciated and that's what I love about
working with this crew and Damien
they're just very loose and willing to
try new things and they take it they
take your thoughts um to heart and I
love that
um and yeah the nightmare scene clown
Cafe you know what man I've got an it's
not that stuck in my head for a while
and it might be because I've known about
it way longer than everybody else but
initially initially when I first heard
it I was like this is a Bop I love this
and I was constantly like we were all
entire Crews like so it was a little
funny and also a lot of the crew members
were in The Nightmare scene like Faye
for example they have like the uh really
cool blonde streak in their hair
um they pull Focus for the film and it
was cool in the film yeah yeah and a
couple other people too but we were all
just singing that freaking song but not
so much anymore I think I think it I'm
desensitized to it sorry I'm pasted but
that's good it gives me hope that
eventually it will get out of my head
eventually but it's great yeah great
song catchy as hell I love it now also
one of my favorite scenes in this film
and I like that it's actually creating
some gifs and memes for is in the
Halloween store with art and Sienna and
arts making these faces too Sienna did
you ever Great Character during that and
was he doing a lot more stuff we'd even
see like was there a lot of improvising
kind of going on in that there was a
tremendous amount of improv and again
that's a testament to Damian as a
director he was very loose with his
actors and he was very like willing to
let us play and I loved that and Dave is
like an improv Master he's so great at
like pulling stuff out and just always
giving you something new each take I'm
trying to wonder if I did actually break
because that was a very long day I think
I was exhausted by the time I got to
that scene so to be fair I don't think I
broke because I just wanted to like get
through it and also that was a crazy day
because I had like an audition oh no I
had to do a a commercial in Philadelphia
and we had filmed at Abracadabra in New
York so I didn't get any sleep and we
had an overnight that night so I had to
drive from New York to Philly to do
another job immediately so I had no
sleep that day for like two days
um so I don't think I broke because I my
mind was like oh [ __ ] I have so much to
do today let me just get through this
let's just get through this but I would
have if I was at a different mindset
because Dave is hilarious
so the exhaustion helped you stay in
character so it's kind of a good thing
you're a little tired so way to use that
for character I like that
uh we also see I actually like Sienna's
room a lot because she's got a lot of
these like different pictures on her
wall and there's a lot of detail to it
did you get to pick some of the items in
her room and how much did that kind of
help you just being in there getting the
mindset of Sienna in this character yeah
let me take a moment to talk about Olga
Turka who did the set design and
wardrobe she designed that entire
because that was a set that wasn't a
real room she designed that room yeah
like it was a set and we we didn't have
a set for every room but that was one of
the sets that wasn't a real room that
was built and created from scratch and
she I think she most artists again like
to inject themselves in the room and she
did that and she she's just she has this
wonderful eye in this wonderful style so
she was able to read the script see what
Sienna's like inject some of herself and
she asked me to bring some of my own
belongings to make it more like me so I
definitely brought some knickknacks I
brought some little like trinkets or
some clothes and I also brought my own
pictures of myself as a baby where oh
wow yes yeah there's actually a moment
where Sienna had just got done having a
panic attack and she looks at herself or
she looks at pictures of herself as a
baby and there's pictures of me as a
baby wearing Wings because I used to
wear Wings constantly as a baby because
I wanted it to be a Halloween time so it
was pretty serendipitous and like a
little a little wild that that was um
that ended up in the film but yeah
definitely got to bring my own things
yeah there's your little uh Lauren
Lavera Easter eggs in the film I'm gonna
have to re-watch and catch all those
um really see me as a baby it's pretty
wild that's cool um also too there's
this I mean really disturbing stuff
happens with Sienna's friend Ally uh you
know Ali just misses your phone call
just a little late
um but with such a gruesome death scene
like that does Lauren herself like what
are you feeling as queasy watching that
scene as we are is are you one of those
people are you kind of like yeah give me
more like what what is your reaction to
that that's definitely one of my
favorite scenes because I of course read
the script first and I remember when I
first got to that scene I was like wait
what and I had to go back and read it
like I must have read it five times in a
row because I couldn't like wrap my head
around what I was reading and especially
the thing that hit me the most was when
she lifts her head and says mom I think
I actually started tearing up because it
like it struck me so much I was like
holy God what the hell is happening but
I think the thing that struck me the
most was how it literally felt like
Damien lifted that scene from The Script
and just threw through it on screen
because it was exactly how I pictured it
from reading it from the script so I
think when I watch it I'm not so much
queasy as I am in all of the Artistry
that went into it I'm just so impressed
with all the hard work everybody
involved put into it and they achieved
what I exactly what I imagined so I'm
just an all when I see it yeah I
actually like that answer a lot too
because that is the feeling I get
watching that and that like her mom's
seeing her still alive in that state and
it adds to that higher art of and making
it really terrifying too absolutely
really smart answer and I'm also
interesting too because this is such a
disturbing heavy film it's not just
visually disturbing but there's heavy
duty backstory for the character of
Sienna I mean we learned that her father
killed himself and was abusive towards
the end lost his mind a bit are you able
for a role like this knowing that
character Arc and backstory like is it
easy for you to snap in and out of such
a dark space and also being on a set of
a very disturbing movie like was that
tough for you
I think for the most part it was it was
challenging but it wasn't too bad there
were definitely moments like I remember
because when you're on set with like a
really small crew you all like tend to
joke around you all tend to like kind of
like waste a little bit of time but
there were moments when I thought I we
were about to film and I would get
myself to a place and I would start
thinking the thoughts of the character
that that's what really helps me I I
create a world for the character and I
start to think the thoughts that I think
the character would think and there was
a moment where I was getting to this
dark place and I think Damien saw it and
I'll never forget it because I
appreciated it so much and everyone was
kind of [ __ ] around but you know they
do sometimes not a big deal and Jamie
and Saul that I was like there and he
was like all right Lauren's ready let's
go like he was like everybody stop let's
go and I really appreciated that because
like he could have just let everybody
keep talking and you know screw around
which is totally fine but he saw that I
was ready so he was able to like we all
really listen to each other which I
really appreciated it was like a lot of
communication and it was really a collab
experience yeah I like you mentioned the
collaborative experience as as you had
talked about too with the production
design cost design that's great too and
I also like you just mentioned about
thinking as your character's thoughts
and I totally see that in your
performance so Props to you because that
shows on your face when you're acting so
really that's great to hear that you're
thinking like that too because it shows
and
um I'm also wondering too this amazing
moment that we see the satisfying moment
to me in the film where Sienna slices
Arts head off but it comes off
incredible and of course the special
effects are awesome but your acting too
brings it to life so when you were
making that though and that you filmed
that scene I don't know if you filmed an
order or not but was there a moment ever
on set where you were like okay we're
making magic here or that you would
think even that it would become this
kind of hit
it's so I that's a good question because
I I think I believed in the script
pretty early on I believe did it pretty
quickly and Damian likes to tell this
story and it's actually that same day
um he's often told the story because
people have asked him in interviews like
what's your favorite moment on the set
and I love that he remembers this moment
because I was freezing we filmed that in
February in on the east coast in a
basement it was grimy I was wet I was
half naked I was covered in [ __ ] covered
in mud covered in blood and Damien he's
exhausted he hasn't gotten any sleep and
then he looks at me and I'm just like
smiling and I I'm uncomfortable no doubt
and like miserable but I'm smiling at
him and he's like oh okay like she's in
a different place which I was I in that
moment was ready to go I was like yeah
something special and I think I believe
in you and I believe in everybody else
here and let's [ __ ] do this and I and
I he got that just from a smile and he
thought he tells the story often and I
love that he remembers it because like I
kind of forgot about it until he brought
it up but like there were those moments
that we would all silently kind of look
at each other like all right let's get
to work because we want to tell this
story and we're having a great time
doing it
yeah and I think what I'm learning about
you today too is you're really good at
like taking whatever current environment
you're in and bringing it to the scene
bringing that feeling mood so that's
cool that's great just advice for
upcoming actors too oh yeah so also you
are in such a special scenario that not
many people can say there where you're
breaking out right now you're get you're
getting all this like just attention
it's great and success but you know most
people it might be like oh I can show my
family it's like a rom-com I'm breaking
at it this type of film like can you go
and sit and watch a grandma or like is
it just like oh I'll just trust your
word of mouth about it like how have you
experienced that with friends family
like is it something where some of them
just can't see it because it's too much
you know fair enough I've had some
people in my life that are like oh I
really want to see it and I'm like do
you know what it's about like you know
they're like oh that's just a horror
film right and I'm like yeah but it's
glory and they're like oh and I'm like
it's gory and like okay so I I feel like
I've told some people like I don't want
them to watch it if it's not their thing
like I don't want them to be offended so
there have been a couple people but I'm
like I want to support you and I'm like
you don't have to it's okay but also on
the flip side of that I've had some
friends that do not like hard but
they're like going to the theaters right
now I took a friend on opening night and
she was so loud like she was so like she
was like I was like please oh my God I
didn't want people to know I was there I
was like please stop please stop she was
like
sad it was so funny but um yeah I've had
both ends of the spectrum people that
are like you know what maybe I'll skip
this one and congratulations and other
people that don't even like horror were
so gung-ho about it they were just so
excited for me so yeah yeah no hell yeah
that's good that's you know everyone if
your friends in something like this you
go support you do you push through
um
now I just want to bring up two before I
let you go because it's amazing just
watching obviously the publicity of this
film the success it's become and the
praise to your great performance and
rightfully so but what blew me away was
that you tweeted a picture of a tattoo
someone got of Sienna you got Stephen
King's approval you got Mike Flanagan's
approval mere hours ago and you're 34
the IMDb star meter so
you I'm telling you that that means you
are a legendary horror final girl you
did it you made it so do you feel like
you're just gonna like spontaneously
combust now how do you even process this
and have you given your self a moment to
Pat yourself on the back for Christ's
sake no I haven't oh gosh thank you that
thank you for reminding me of all those
things yeah it's pretty wild I actually
had a bit of a cry earlier over my
Flanagan's tweet because I love him and
I love to work with him like I was just
like oh my God like it didn't sink in
that like he cared enough to watch it
and say nice words about my performance
so that that was probably the first time
I frapped a bit because this entire job
hasn't felt real but today I cried like
I mean I just gave myself about a minute
or two and I was like okay I got [ __ ] to
do today I'll cry about this more later
so there are definitely moments and even
talking to fans I think talking to fans
have have felt the most like oh my God
this is so special because this connects
with so many people and I'm so grateful
for all the other things you know know
Stephen King and Mike Flanagan but it's
really the fans that have made this
experience the most special and most
wonderful time of my life so yeah yeah
for sure and it is special it's a
special film it's a special performance
and I think what's the magic of movies
is that we're gonna feel now attached to
your character attach your performance
and in a sense we feel more attached to
you as an actor so we get excited for
okay what's she gonna do next so is
there anything you can kind of plug or
anything you're excited about just in
your life podcasts shows movies anything
that you might be doing next yeah I just
got out of some meetings today I have
even more next week's a lot of offers a
lot of scripts sent my way I'm very
excited about it yeah and they're all
they're all over the place in terms of
genre you'd think it would be all hard
but it's really not and I'm exciting
because you are sometimes like oh am I
going to get pigeonholed which would be
fine because I do love heart but like
they're seeing I'm seeing range on
coming into my email so I'm really
excited about that but um I can't really
talk about a lot because I've signed
some ndas however I did do a film a
couple months ago with Bill Mosley it's
called the fetus I play his daughter
Bill Moseley's amazing he was the main
reason I wanted to work on the film
because he's just incredible but
everybody else was really wonderful
Julian Curtis who plays my boyfriend in
the film and all the other cast and crew
which is phenomenal so that's one thing
I can talk about for now yeah that's
exciting I can't wait to see that is
that a horror film too or is it
different genre no nice Definitely it's
definitely it's more I think it's even
more body hard too so oh cool who knows
yeah I can't wait and I can't wait for
all the future projects and those emails
to turn to amazing things can't wait
um Everybody tell your friends about
terrifier too watch it again bring
people to theater let's just make this
thing keep going and ride this
successful train and watch Lauren kill
it Lauren thank you so much for joining
me today I hope to talk to you in the
future uh Steve thank you so much it was
such a pleasure